اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى تغطيتنا المستمره
والمباشره لليوم الثاني عشر على التوالي
للحرب في السودان ولليوم الثاني من ايام
الهدنه الهشه تستمر المواجهات الجيش
السوداني اكد ان قناصه الدعم السريع
يطلقون النار في مطار الخرطوم وبحري وام
درمان مع رصد ارتال للدعم السريع تتجه من
كردفان ودارفور الى الخرطوم المواجهات خلف
الضحايا جدد حيث قالت نقابه اطباء السودان
في بيانها اليومي قالت ان عدد الوفيات بين
المدنيين ارتفع الى 295 حاله وفاه بينما
تم تسجيل اكثر من 1700 حاله اصابه بين
المدنيين منذ بدايه الاشتباكات وذكرت
النقابه ان هناك العديد من الاصابات
والوفيات غير مشموله لعدم التمكن من
الوصول للمستشفيات لصعوبه التنقل والوضع
الامني في البلاد
[موسيقى]
اما من حيث عمليات الاجلاء حيث تواصل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه جهودها عبر
موانئ جده في البحر الاحمر لانقاذ
الجاليات الاجنبيه الهاربه من الحرب في
السودان وفي هذا السياق اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه ان سفينه تقل اكثر من
1680 مدنيا من اكثر من 50 دوله فالرو من
العنف في السودان قد وصلت بالفعل الى
السعوديه الاربعاء في اكبر عمليه انقاذ من
نوعها تنفذها السعوديه حتى الان وزاره
الخارجيه في بيان اكدت حرص المملكه على
توفير كامل الاحتياجات الاساسيه للرعايه
الاجانب وذلك تمهيدا لتسهيل مغادرتهم الى
بلدانهم اما قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في
جده مشاهدينا كانت على اهبه الاستعداد منذ
الساعات الاولى لفجر اليوم لتمثيل اكبر
عمليه اجلاء حتى الان من السودان وذلك
بوصول ثالث موكب اجلاء قادما من فورد
سودان السفينه وصلت تحت حمايه القوات
البحريه السعوديه وعلى متنها 1687 شخصا من
ثمانيه او 58 جنسيه سفينه الاجلاء كانت
تقول ثلاثه عشره سعوديا وسته واربعين
امريكيا واربعين بريطانيا بالاضافه الى 11
المانيا واربعه فرنسيين
و560 اندونيسيا
و239 يمنيا وسته وعشرين تركيا
امامكم في الكاميرا عدد من الممثلين
والسفراء والدبلوماسيين لهؤلاء الرعايه
لاستقبالهم وانهاء كافه اجراءات سفرهم من
قبل الحكومه السعوديه ومن قبل ممثلينهم
بشكل كبير جدا خلال الفتره او خلال ساعه
الى ساعتين سوف يتم منها كافه اجراءات
السفر التابعه لهؤلاء الرعايه سوف تستمر
عمليه انزال كما ذكرنا قبل قليل من ساعه
ونصف الى ساعتين ونصف سوف يتم انهاء
الاجراءات ونزولهم الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه ومن ثم الى مقرات السكن سوف يتم
استقبالهم بالاعلام وبالورود وبالحلوى كما
هو المعتاد نتحدث عن عمليات اجلاء استمرت
لمده ثلاثه ايام هذه هي السفينه او الموكب
الثالث والسفينه السادسه التي عملت على
نقل الرعايه من بورتسودان وسطه
قوات البحريه السعوديه ووزاره وبالتنسيق
مع وزاره الخارجيه والسفر السعوديه في
الخرطوم وعدد كبير من قطعه الحكوميه التي
صخرت كافه جهدها للتعامل مع الرعايه او
التعامل مع ملف الرعايه واستقبالهم بشكل
كبير وبعمليات اجلاء مستمره منذ ثلاثه
ايام وحتى هذه اللحظه من المتوقع خلال
الساعات القادمه ان تكون هنالك رحلات
اجلاء قادمه من بورد سودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه سوف نستمر بتغطيه عمل
الملف والعمليات الاجلاء المستمره اللي من
قبل الحكومه السعوديه
للرعايه الدول الشقيقه والدول العربيه
والدول الاجنبيه
والله احنا تم اجلالنا بالباصات الى
بورسودان ومن بعدها يعني مكرمه المملكه
يعني بارك الله فيهم واخذنا بالعبارات
تقريبا الساعه سبعه الصباح غادرنا من
بورسودان والحين وصلنا اول المملكه الحمد
لله على سلامه الجميع مده اقامتنا تقريبا
سبع سنوات او اكثر شوي كنا مقيمين بمنطقه
بحري كافوري شو المعاناه والمشاهد اللي
انتم عشتوها في السودان اثناء الاشتباكات
يعني هو الرعب الطياره من فوقك كيف هيك عم
تقصف يعني رعب كان فظيع مذيعه يا محمد
معانا
يعني رعب نفسي وجسدي
والله كنا بالسودان بالعاصمه الخرطوم في
الخرطوم نفسها الخرطوم نفسه وكان في يعني
نسمع اصوات تقريبا كذا واخر فتره لما
قللنا انه خلص بدنا نطلع فكانت الضرب قوي
جدا يعني صراحه كان كل شي منظم ما شاء
الله وكان كذا في جنود وكلهم قاعدين
يعطونا ترتيبات يعني فكان الموضوع جدا سهل
الحمد لله وصلتوا مع السفاره السعوديه هنا
تواصلوا معاهم قالوهم قالوا لهم نروح على
الميناء البري البحري
وجينا والحمد لله كل شيء كان سهل
ومع دخول عمليات الاجلاء من السودان يومها
السادس وكبت كاميرا العربيه العمليات في
عده دول حيث يشهد مطار بورت سودان الدولي
شرقي البلاد يشهد رحلات اجلاء بواقع ثلاث
رحلات جويه يوميا وعلى متنها مئات الرعايه
من الدول الاجنبيه والبعثات الدبلوماسيه
والموظفين الامميين وبينما تتوالد دفعات
وصلت احدى طائرات الاجلاء الى بيروت
بمساعده سعوديه محمله باثنين وثلاثين شخصا
بينهم اثني عشر فلسطينيا يحملون اوراقا
لبنانيه كما تمر عمليه الاجلاء الى ليبيا
عبر ثلاث مراحل بريه وجويه وبحريه تبدا
بالانتقال بالحافلات الى بورتسودان ثم
الترحيل الى ميناء جده وصولا الى المحطه
الاخيره والسفر بالطائره الى طرابلس
واستقبل مطار مع تاج الدولي استقبل
105 اشخاص من الجاليه اللي بيه في السودان
بعد اجلائهم بسبب الاشتباكات الدائره هناك
وكانت قد اكدت الجزائر ان 13 فلسطينيا
واثنين وعشرين سوريا وعددا اخر من اعضاء
سفارتهم في الخرطوم قدموا من مطار
بورتسودان على متن طائره عسكريه تابعه
للجيش الوطني الشعبي
بدورها اعلنت هيئه الموانئ البريه في مصر
اعلنت تجاوز القادمين من السودان الذين
تمكنوا من دخول البلاد عبر معبره يقسطل
وارقين عشره الاف شخص وقالت في بيان لها
ان القادمين من السودان من مختلف الجنسيات
مع تكثيف العاملين في المنفذين من اداره
الجوازات والجمارك وغيرها من الجهات
لاستيعاب الكثافه المتوقعه
هذا وقال مسؤول في البحريه الامريكيه
لشبكه سي ان ان قال ان الولايات المتحده
سترسل سفينه حربيه ثالثه الى السودان
تمتاز بسرعه عاليه نسبيا وذلك بعد يوم
واحد من اعلان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان
وصول سفينه للسواحل السودانيه
ووصول سفينه وتوجه اخرى من بحر العرب الى
هناك واضاف المسؤول البحري ان السفن
الثلاث قادره على نقل مئات الاطنان من
المعدات او عدد كبير من الافراد بسرعات
عاليه نسبيا
اذا مشاهدينا نقول لكم صور مباشره لمطار
الخرطوم
وقناصه من الدعم السريع بحسب اتهامات
الجيش طبعا يقومون
بقنص الاشخاص وتواصل اطلاق النار في
الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري وام درمان اذا هذه
صور مباشره ننقلها لكم من مطار الخرطوم
حيث هناك اتهامات من الجيش السوداني بان
قناصه الدعم السريع مستمره في اطلاق النار
في مطار الخرطوم وبحري وام درمان
وزاره الدفاع الالمانيه مشاهدينا كشفت
انها انتهت من عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
موضحه انها اكملت اجلاء اجلاء نقلت خلاله
اكثر من 700 شخص الى خارج السودان بينهم
200 مواطن الماني
من ميناء جده الاسلامي معنا مراسل العربيه
هنصفيا اهلا بك هاني اذا انت في ميناء جده
الاسلامي تنقل لنا
استمراريه وصول الاشخاص من السودان عمليات
الاجلاء السعوديه قائمه لعده مواطنين من
دول مختلفه انقل لنا الصوره لديك
نعم اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدين قناه العربيه
العربيه ما زالت تواكب عمليه اجلاء رعايه
من جنسيات مختلفه والذين يصلون بشكل
متتابع الى جده الواقعه غرب السعوديه هذه
المره هي السعوديه سمحت بالفرقاطه
الفرنسيه لورين وهي واحده من الفرقاطات
العسكريه التي الان تحمل قرابه ال400 شخص
من جنسيات مختلفه ويتبعون للامم المتحده
طبعا هذه الفرقاطه قبل نصف ساعه وصلت من
الان وهي الان في لحظات الاولى التي
ننتظرها لنزول
الاشخاص التي تقلهم هذه
الفرقاطه وكان اتحدث قبل قليل ايضا معنى
ممثل الامم المتحده للطفوله السيد الطيب
ادم والذي تحدث ان هناك قرابه 400 شخص
جنسيات متعدده من امريكا والمانيا
وايطاليا وكذلك جنسيات من بعض اوروبا
الشماليه وصلوا على متن هذه السفينه بعضهم
يعاني من حالات صحيه وذلك ايضا دفع سلطات
السعوديه الى تواجد فرق طبيه وصحيه من اجل
رعايتهم وكذلك ايصالهم الى المستشفى
المخصص والمعد لهم وايضا نشاهد الجهود
الامنيه التي تقوم بها السعوديه من اجل
استقبال هذه البعثه او هؤلاء الرعايه
لنتحدث بشكل تفصيلي ايضا وايضا ينضم معي
ضيف جديد وهو الاستاذ محمد الغنيم وهو
ممثل في البرنامج الاغذيه العالمي مرحبا
بك استاذ محمد اليوم يعني تصل الفرقاطه
ولكن الفرقاطه اعتادت دائما ما تصل
السعوديه في تمارين مشتركه مع وزاره
الدفاع ولكن اليوم تسمح لها السعوديه
بالوقوف على الرصيف ميناء جدا الاسلامي من
اجل اجلام رعايه من دول عده من بورتو
سودان اولا كيف تمت هذه العمليه ما هي
المراسلات التي تمت بين الامم المتحده
وبين السعوديه وكيف ايضا
كان رد السعوديه في السماح لهذه الفرقاطة
بالوقوف على هذا الرسم
اولا اشكرك اخي العزيز على التغطيه
المميزه
واشكر صراحه المملكه الانسانيه العربيه
السعوديه على وقفاتها الدائمه مع العالم
بشتى
اصنافه
والوانهم حاليا
الفرقه الطلب تم عن طريق الامم المتحده
تم الطلب الى حكومه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بالمساعده في اجلاء موظفين الامم
المتحده الى
ميناء جده الاسلامي ومن ثم اجلائهم عن
طريق طائرات الامم المتحده الى
محطات وصول مخطط لها
ابتدا بطلب من منظومه الامم المتحده الى
مقام وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ولا اخفيك
سرا
كانت الاستجابه سريعه وايجابيه
مما كان له الاثر على العاملين لنا والاثر
الاكبر على المستفيدين للناس اللي كانوا
موجودين في في ميناء بور السودان
حاليا هذه الدفعه الاولى الدفعه الثانيه
ان شاء الله بتكون غدا او بعد غد
وبنحاء
وبعد الدفعه الثانيه سنرى اذا كان
في طلب اكثر لاجلاء
بنحاول ان شاء الله انه احنا نظمنهم على
نفس الخطه الحاليه انت تحدثت عن نقطه ان
عمليه الاستجابه بالنسبه للسعوديه لطلب
الامم المتحده كان سريع
حكم دائما الامم المتحده هو برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه
للاستعانه ببعض الدول هل الاستجابه تكون
سريعه ام تكون هناك بعض المعوقات التي
تواجهونها
لا اخفيك
توجد بعض
خليني اكون واضح وصريح الا هي تكون على
حسب الامكانيات
وحسب
احتياج الوضع القائم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
حتى الان لا اخفيك لم تتردد في طلب بل
كانت استجابتهم سريعه في مواضيع تفوق
مواضيع
اخلاء اللاجئين او اخلاء اسف موظفين الامم
المتحده
المملكه العربيه السعوديه شعارها في اخر
اخر عشر سنوات الوقوف مع المحتاجين في اي
بقع في العالم فهذا
هو كان مصدر او الدافع اللي جعل الامم
المتحده او جعلنا نتقدم الى مقام المملكه
الانسانيه العربيه السعوديه نشاهد ايضا
هنا فرق طبيه من وزاره الصحه السعوديه
ويبدو ان هناك بعض الحالات من ضمن عمليات
الاجراء التي تعاني من حاله صحيه او طبيه
نعم صحيح لدينا بعض
الحالات تقريبا عدد ست حالات
وبعد بعد ما تاكدنا من الست حالات من
ميناء بور السودان تم الطلب من من حكومه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه مشكوره
وتمت تم تحضير الامكانيات الهائله
والعظيمه اللي نراها الان شكرا لك استاذ
محمد يعطيك العافيه اذا هذه الان المشاهد
ايضا نشاهد الفرقه الطبيه السعوديه تقوم
بالاستعداد للصعود او ايضا اخذ مكانها
المناسب من اجل الصحيه وهي ست حالات
صحيه علامتنا هذه السفينه اليوم نتحدث عن
400 شخص على متن هذه الفرقاطه وكذلك ايضا
هناك كما تحدث الاستاذ محمد ان هناك ايضا
فرقاطه اخرى سوف تتبع هذه الفرقاطه من
المتوقع ان تكون غد او بعد غد طبعا هناك
استعدادات امنيه من قبل حرس الحدود
السعودي اتابع لوزاره الداخليه نتحدث ايضا
عن تواجد امني من قبل اداره الشرط وكذلك
الادارات الامنيه الاخرى التابعه لوزاره
الداخليه وايضا فرق صحيه وايضا لا ننسى
ايضا دور في من قبل وزاره النقل وكذلك من
جده الاسلامي الذي ايضا
مكنه خدماته اللوجستيه وكذلك صخره امكانيه
امكانياته اللوجستيه من اجل وقوف هذه
الفرقاطه هنا نشاهد ايضا
الكابتن او الكابتن الخاص بالفرقاطه
الفرنسيه يتحدث مع ممثل الامم المتحده
الطيب ادم وكذلك هنا العقيد عبد الرحمن
الحارثي وهو قائد الحرس الحدود هنا في هذا
الميناء يقومون بالتشاور الاخير في عمليه
ونزول هؤلاء الذين تم حملهم على هذه
الفرقاطه طبعا هذه الفرقات التي نتحدث
فيها لون الطلع قليلا عليها وهي فرقاط
اعتادت الوصول الى السعوديه ولكن المشاركه
في تمارين عسكريه مع السعوديه ولكن اليوم
هي يسمح لها بالوقوف على هذا الرصيف من
اجل اجلام رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده الذين
وصلوا للتو ممثل الامم المتحده في حديث
سابق او في نشره الماضيه تحديدا تحدث ان
هناك قرابه الالف 1400 او قرابه الالف شخص
من بعثات الامم المتحده من جنسيات مختلفه
اوروبيه وامريكيه يتواجدون
في بورتو سودان يتم اجلاؤهم الان على شكل
دفعات وهذه هي الدفعه الاولى هو تحدث لنا
ايضا او تحدث للعربيه ان على ان هم بخير
وسلام وامان في بورتو سودان الجزء او
الدفعه الاولى هي وصلت الان وبقي دفعه
اخرى سوف تصل خلال اليومين القادمين ايضا
هنا مركبات الاسعاف للهلال الاحمر السعودي
وهو احد القطاعات الصحيه المعني بنقل
دائما الاصابات الطارئه وكذلك السريعه
والتي تحتاج دائما الى نقلها الى
المستشفيات التي المعنيه بوزاره الصحه
نقوم ايضا او نشاهد بهذه المركبات
المتطوره والحديثه ولو نقوم ايضا نستعرض
بعض الامكانيات الصحيه على هذه المركبه
حتى يتم نزول الركاب من الداخل لا نشاهد
هذه الامكانيات كيف هي مجهزه ومؤمنه من
خلال الاسره الطبيه ومن خلال ايضا احدث
الاجهزه الطبيه المتوفره داخل هذه المركبه
وهي واحده من خمس مركبات او ست مركبات
عفوا تتواجد على هذا الرصيف هنا ما زالت
طبعا نشاهد على ظهر السفينه او ايضا على
ظهر
الفرقاطه
المرحله الاخيره من الاجراءات التي يقوم
بها اعظام او الجنود الفرقاطه للتاكد من
اعداد البعثه قبل نزولهم وعلى هذا الرصيف
واستقبالهم من قبل البعثه المتحده بجانب
ايضا الجهات الامنيه السعوديه
تواجدها اليوم هي من اجل حمايتهم وامنهم
وايضا يحرص على سلامتهم ونشاهد ايضا افراد
من قبل حرس الحدود يقومون بالدخول
والصعودي لعلامه هذه الفرقاطه ايضا
وضوح او التاك من الاسماء التي سوف
تكون على هذا الرصيف او سوف تغادر
الفرقاطه وبعد ذلك يتم نقلهم عبر حافلات
ايضا لو نستعرض الحافلات نشاهدها ايضا في
الخلف نشاهد الحافلات هناك اكثر من سبع
باصات او سبع حافلات وفرتها السعوديه من
اجل نقل هؤلاء الرعايه من هذا الميناء الى
الفنادق المخصصه نحن نتحدث اليوم عن عده
فنادق جهزتها السعوديه
سواء
لهؤلاء البعثه او كذلك لعمليات الاجلال
للرعايه التي قامت بها السعوديه عبر سفنها
التابعه للقوات البحريه السعوديه والتي
اشرفت عليها هذه هي الحافلات الان المجهزه
والمهيئه سوف تكون جاهزه ومؤمنه في حال
وصول او نزول المباشر من قبل رعايه بعث ه
الامم المتحده هنا في ميناء جده الاسلامي
نعم شكرا هاني لك على هذه المعلومات سنبقى
معك ونتابع معك بالتاكيد نزول الاشخاص
الذين تم اجلائهم علامات هذه الفرقاطه
ونعود اليك اللاحقا
جدل متصاعد بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع حيالفرار سجناء من سجن كوبر
المركزي الجدل تركز اكثر على حقيقه هروب
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير ردا على ذلك اكد
الجيش السوداني ان الرئيس السابق عمر
البشير لا يزال محتجزا في مستشفى عسكري
تحت حراسه الشرطه القضائيه وقال في بيان
له ان البشير واعاده من قيادات حزبه
محتجزون في مستشفى علياء العسكري وعبر عن
رفضه لاي محاولات لربط ما يجري في السجون
بمزايدات على مواقفنا الوطنيه ووصف الجيش
السوداني الدعم السريع وقائده بانهم ربيبه
العهد البائد
الجيش السوداني كان قد اتهم قوات الدعم
السريع بالوقوف وراء العمليه وقال في بيان
له ان سلطه اداره السجون خارج نطاق
اختصاصه وتقع تحت مسؤوليه وزاره الداخليه
واشار الجيش الى انه لا مصلحه له في خروج
النزلاء من سجونهم بهذه الطريقه التي تضع
امن الناس وطمانينتهم على المحك مضيفه
مضيفا انه غير معني باي بيانات تصدر من اي
جماعه او افراد خرجوا من السجون
من جهته اتهمها المستشار السياسي لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع يوسف عزت اتهم قيادات
مواليه للبشير في الجيش باطلاق سراح
قيادات النظام السابق من سجن كوبر واضاف
في تصريحات للعربيه ان مغادره قيادات نظام
البشير للسجن كان امرا متوقعا
ولد اليوم الاول لانقلاب الحركه الاسلاميه
الذي يدبره على كرتي نتوقع كل هذا العناصر
الاسلاميه داخل الجيش انا لا اتهم كل
الجيش الجيش ليس كله حركه اسلاميه هنالك
ضباط شرفاء ولكن هنالك جهات داخل
الاستخبارات العسكريه هنالك جهات الضباط
اسلاميين ساهموا في اطلاق سراحه هذه
المجموعه او نحن لدينا معلومات من داخل
السجن لحظه اطلاق النار لحظه اقتحام السجن
لحظه اطلاق سراحهم ولكن كانت قواتنا لم
تكن قريبه من الموقع
للسيطره على هذه العمليه
مشاهدينا نعود الى مراسلناها نصفيان
والصور المباشره للفرقاه التي وصلت الى
جده ويبدو انهم يقومون بانزال مصابين من
علامتنا هذه الفرقات القادمه من السودان
والتي تنقل
وتجلي اشخاص من السودان بعد هروبهم طبعا
من الازمه والمعارك هناك اذا نشاهد احد
المصابين الذين تم انزالهم من الفرقات
الفرنسيه التي وصلت الى ميناء جده في
السعوديه ويتم اسعافهم وادخالهم الى
مركبات الاسعاف المتوفره
لمعالجه لتوفير الخدمه الصحيه اللازمه لاي
مصاب باثرى المعارك في السودان اذا
السعوديه تقدم
مساعدات انسانيه ومساعدات صحيه لكل من
ياتون الى السعوديه قادمين من السودان
هربنا من المعارك بين الجيش والدعم السريع
اذا ننقل لكم هذه الصور المباشره مشاهدينا
للمصابين الذين ينزلون من الفرقات
الفرنسيه التي وصلت اليوم الى ميناء جده
في الغرب السعودي هاني هل تسمعني
نعم انا اسمعك فاطمه اذا الان بدا نزول
الاشخاص على متن او رعايه بعثه الامم
المتحده ونشاهد ايضا هذه السيده والتي
ترافقها احدى المجندات السعوديات من الحرس
من حرس الحدود وكذلك نون من حرس الحدود
يرافقونها في عمليه نزولهم وهي من الدفعه
الاولى طبعا سبق نزول هذه السيده ايضا احد
الاشخاص الذين ذكرهم السيد طيب ادم ممثل
الامم المتحده للطفوله والذي تحدث هناك ست
اشخاص يعانون من حاله صحيه تم توفير
مركبات اسعافيه وقد قبل قليل التقطنا بعض
الصور
لهذه الحاله والان نلتقط ايضا هذه الصور
لحظه نزول
كبار السن
والاحتياجات الطبيه التي يحتاجونها او فئه
الفئات المخصصه للاحتياجات الطبيه هم
يقومون به النزول والتوجه مباشره الى
مركبه الاسعاف كما نشاهد التي خصصتها
الصحه وهي هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي
وكذلك السلطات السعوديه وتامين صحه وسلامه
رايه بعثه الامم المتحده
ومغادرتهم سواء ممن يحتاج الى المستشفى او
كذلك مغادره البعثه الاخرى الى المقر
الفنادق المخصصه لهم طبعا بينما ايضا نقوم
برصد هذه الصور دعا اننا نوضح ايضا بعض
المعلومات ونعيد بعض المعلومات لنؤكد
للساده المشاهدين الذي فاته خبرنا عن وصول
بعثه الامم او بعثه من راى الامم المتحده
الى ميناء جده الاسلامي قادمه عبر فرقاطه
فرنسيه وهي فرقه لورين قادمه من ميناء
بورتو السودان والتي وصلت قبل نصف ساعه
تحمل هذه الفرقاطه قرابه ال400
شخص من جنسيات مختلفه هناك السلك
الدبلوماسي لعدد من الدول سواء الدول من
اوروبا وكذلك امريكا وهم ايضا سوف
يستقبلون بعض رعاياهم من بعثه الامم
المتحده يتواجدون الان هنا على رصيف ميناء
جده الاسلامي هنا ايضا وصول او نزول ايضا
المزيد من
بعثه الامم المتحده ورعايه الامم المتحده
الذين وصلوا للتو الان وهم يغادرون وايضا
نشاهد هنا احد الاطفال الذي الان يحمله
هذا الجندي من افراد حرس الحدود وكذلك
نشاهد ايضا صور اخرى في عمليه مسانده
ومساعده الرجال الامن في الحرس في حرس
الحدود
للاطفال رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده والذين
يصلون في هذه اللحظات وهناك المزيد ايضا
من رعايه بعثته متحدهم على ظهر الس
ونشاهدهم ايضا على ظهر السفينه هناك ولكن
يقومون بانهاء اجراءاتهم والتاكد ايضا من
معلوماتهم النهائيه قبل نزولهم من هذه
الفرقاطه من قبل جنود الفرقاطه الفرنسيين
الذين يتاكدون من معلوماتهم طبعا الدفعه
سوف تستمر نحن نتحدث عن قرابه اكثر من سبع
حافلات سوف تقول لهم الى مقر مقر اقامتهم
وايضا هناك ست حالات من 400 شخص على هذه
الفرقاطه سوف يغادر الى المستشفى مباشره
لانهم يسكنون من حاله صحيه وهذه حاله صحيه
كما تحدث بها السيد ادم ممثل الامم
المتحده ان حالتهم الصحيه ليس بسبب
اصابتهم بسبب النزاع الحاصل الان في
السودان ولكن بسبب حالتهم الصحيه الطبيعيه
التي يعانون منها في وقت سابق لا توجد هذه
الفرقاطه اي من حاله صحيه اخرى او من ممن
يعانون من ارهاق واذا وجد فان هناك الفرق
الصحيه التابعه لوزاره الصحه السعوديه
وكذلك التي استخرتها السلطات السعوديه من
اجل سلامه وامان وصول البعثه ورايا بعته
الامم المتحده الى الحافلات وبعد ذلك الى
مقر اقامتهم وحتى يتمكنون من المغادره من
الاراضي السعوديه عبر طائرات خصصتها الامم
المتحده لهم وسوف تتم خلال هذا الاسبوع
طبعا لا ننسى ان هناك ايضا العدد او
الدفعه الاخرى سوف تكون او سوف تصل خلال
اليومين القادمين بحسب ايضا ما تحدث
الاستاذ محمد الغنيم وهو ممثل ممثل
الاغنياء الاغذيه العالميه والذي تحدث ان
هناك دفعه اخرى من بعثه الامم المتحده سوف
تصل قرابه او من الممكن يوم غد او بعد غد
اضافه الى هذه الدفعه وبذلك يكون اجمالي
عدد رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده قرابه الالف
شخص الذين يصلون من جده الاسلامي طبعا
اليوم نتحدث ايضا عن موقع تحديدا من جد
الاسلامي لماذا من جد الاسلامي ولماذا
السعوديه او لماذا دول العالم تختار هذه
الوجهه اولا السعوديه سخرت امكانياتها
وكانت استجابتها سريعه لكافه دول العالم
بحسب ايضا حديث ممثل وممتحده وبرنامج
الاغذيه عالمي الذي تحدث بكل شفافيه ان
السعوديه كانت استجابه سريعه سواء
لبعثاتنا او كذلك للدول الاخرى من حيث
الطلبات التي تلقتها باعداد كبيره من دول
عده اليوم نتحدث عن اكثر من 58 دوله
احتاجه اليوم
لاستعانه بالسعوديه من اجل السماح بوصول
رعايا اراضيها وتحديدا الى مدينه جده
الواقعه او قرابه تبعد 300 400 كيلو متر
عن بورتو سودان هناك نعم المسافه قد تكون
قليلا نسبيا ولكن المسافه البحريه قد تطول
بسبب الاجراءات الامنيه وكذلك ايضا عمليه
صعود هؤلاء الرايه من بورتو السودان
والاجراءات التي تتم هناك في السودان
نتحدث ايضا اليوم عن امكانيات اضافيه غير
السفن التي الموفره سواء اللي وفرتها
السعوديه عن طريق او من قبل او ممثله بها
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه او كذلك
السماح بالفرقاطات الاجنبيه مثل هذه
الفرقه الفرنسيه الحربيه التي تقف على هذا
الرصيف والتي سمحت بها السعوديه الوقوف من
اجل نقل هذه الرعايه فانها تحتاج الى
اجراءات كبيره وعديده وتجهيزات وخدمات
لوجستيه من اجل توفير اولا وكذلك اذا
يحتاجون الى ايضا كوادر صحيه وكذلك
الاجراءات الامنيه المتبعه كاي دور
اجراءات امنيه تتبع في كافه دول العالم
ولكن السعوديه اليوم وبحسب ما وصلنا من
خلال بعثات الامم المتحده وكذلك ممثلين
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي هم يتحدثون ان
السلاسه والاستجابه السريعه كانت في مقدمه
الامر فتفوقت او تفوق العمل الانساني وطغى
العمل الانساني على كافه الجوانب الاخرى
من اجل تسهيل وصول
الرعايه الجنسيات المختلفه الى السعوديه
بسلام وامان هنا حاله اخرى الحاله الثالثه
الطبيه التي الان تصل او تنزل الى هذا
الرصيف ويحملها عدد من جنود الفرقاطه
الفرنسيه وبعد ذلك يتم حملها عن طريق
الفرق من حرس الحدود الذين يقومون
بالتوجههم او ايضا اخذ او الاتجاه بها الى
مركبه الاسعاف المخصصه وهي كما ذكرنا قبل
قليل كنا نعرض مركبات الاسعاف التي جهزتها
او جهزها الهلال الاحمر السعودي من اجل
مثل هذه الحالات طبعا يوجد مسعف على كل
مركبه وايضا تجهيزات طبيه وايضا استعدادات
اخرى طبيه حتى يتم نقله الى المستشفى
الخاص بسلام وامان لعل هذه الصور هي صور
خاصه تنقلها العربيه الان من ميناء جده
الاسلامي وهي لوصول بعثات الامم المتحده
وراعي الامم المتحده الى مدينه جده
الواقعه غرب السعوديه وهنا نزول سليم
لاشخاص سليمين ايضا لعدد من الرعايه منهم
الاطفال وكذلك منهم
ونشاهد السعاده على هذا الطفل الذي هو
سعيد جدا
لوصوله بسلام وامان الى مدينه جده يبدو
انه بالفعل هذه الابتسامه تتضح لنا انهم
عانوا من اشياء كثيره ولم يتوقعوا الوصول
الى مدينه جده بسلام ايضا نشاهد السعاده
على احد هذا الاشخاص الذين وصل الان وهو
يتجه الى الحافله المخصصه لهم وهناك ايضا
المزيد وان بدا
العدد يزداد من خلال النزول رايه بعثه على
المتحده الى مدينه جده هم قدمهم من ميناء
بورتو سودان يبدو ان الرحله كانت قرابه
الثمان ساعات
بعد تجهيزهم واستعداداتهم وايضا صعودهم
وايضا الاجراءات الامنيه المتخذه فيها مثل
هذا الامر طبعا لا ننسى ايضا عمليه تامين
الممرات البح ونحن نتحدث اليوم عن تامين
ممر بحري ليس بالسهل هناك العديد من السفن
والعديد من المخاطر التي
قد تواجه دائما السفن وايضا السعوديه امنت
الممر البحري لوصول هذه الفرقاطه مثل
تامينها لوصول السفن التي قامت بها
السعوديه وعلى شاهدنا اليوم في ساعات
الصباح الاولى عن اكبر عمليه اجلاء قامت
بها السعوديه في في جده وتحديدا عبر اجراء
اكثر من
1670 شخص من اربعين جنسيه وصلوا بسلام
وقاموا وقامت القوات البحريه الملكيه
السعوديه بتامين الممر البحري وكما هو
الحال تم تامين ايضا الممر البحري لهذه
الفرقه حتى تصل على رصيف او الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي وتقف على هذا الرصيف بسلام وامان
عن الصيان مراسل العربيه انت معنا من
ميناء جده الاسلامي لتنقل لنا الوصول على
ان الاشخاص الذين تم اجلائهم من السودان
عبر هذه الفرقاطه الفرنسيه مستمرون معك في
هذه التغطيه وسنعود اليك احاله هناك اي
مستجدات شكرا هاني
نعود مشاهدينا الى الجدل المصاحب لهروب
قيادات من نظام البشير من سجن كوبر حيث
قال المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم
السريع يوسف عزت قال للعربيه ان من
مسؤوليات الدعم السريع القاء القبض على
الرئيس المخلوع عمر البشير واحمد هارون
بعد عمليه اجلائهم من السجن
انا لا ليس لدي معلومه عن كيفيه تنفيذ
العمليه او كيفيه اخلاقه من السجن اؤكد لك
هذا هذا مجرد توقعات او احتمالات او
لاشخاص فيهم احمد هارون فيوم عبد الرحيم
محمد
الشعب السوداني طوال 30 سنه نحن من
مسؤوليتنا وفي اطار حربنا والذي يواجهونا
بها من مسؤوليتنا سنسعى بكل ما
يمكن القبض عليهم
الاتهامات المتبادله بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع جاءت تعقيبا على الجدل
المصاحب لتصريحات المسؤول السابق في
النظام البشير احمد هارون والذي قال في
تسجيل صوتي انه مستعد هو والمسؤولون
السابقون الاخرون للمثول امام القضاء
عندما يطلع بدوره
11 ابريل 2019 بما في ذلك حبسنا كرهائن
لديها طلبا لرضا سياسيه واخرى اقليميه
ودوليه ثبت الان انها العدو الاول للشعب
السوداني وللسلطه القائمه ولقواته المسلحه
فهي من تسببت في الحرب الدائره الان ونفرغ
تماما ما بين القائمين على تلك السلطه
ومؤسسات الدوله الوطنيه وفي مقدمتها
قواتنا المسلحه التي تقاتل بشرف وبشجاعه
وبساله كالعدي بها دوما وندعو كل جماهير
شعبنا
وعضويتنا لمزيد من الالتفاف حولها
ومساندتها واستراح المبادره التي تسند
دورها الوطني الذي تقوم به الان جماهير
شعبنا الوفيه ظلنا كقيادات ثوره الانقاذ
الوطني بمحبسنا بكوبرا تحت تقاطع نيران
المعرفه الدائره الان
لمده تسعه ايام نتشارك وبقيه نزلاء السين
وسجانيه تلك الظروف الامنيه الاستثنائيه
وانعدام مقومات الحياه من انقطاع تام
للمياه والكهرباء والطعام والرعايه الصحيه
حتى للجرحى من جراء تساقط النيران وسط قوه
السجون والنزلاء والتي توفى من جرائها
العديد منهم وجرح اخر ومنفجار الاوضاع
داخل السجن بخروج كل النزلاء يوم الاحد 23
ابريل 2023 من السجن عنوه
حتى خلا تماما من نزلائه وسفيانه فيما عدا
قله لا تتجاوز العشره من قاده وضباط
وافراد وبناء على طلب القوه المتبقيه من
قوه السجون تحركنا لموقع اخر خارج السي
تحت حراسه محدوده لا تتعدى الثلاثه من تلك
القوه على امل ان تتحصل سلطات السجون على
امر القضائي بالافراج عنا حسب افادتها
خلال ذلك اليوم لنواجه مع جماهير شعبنا
ذات ظروفه وتحدياته والقيام معه بذات
الواجبات الوطنيه فلم تعد هناك سيون قائمه
ولا مقار لمباشره اجهزه ووكالات انفاز
القانون لمهامها وهكذا في الانقياده
ضريبتها والتزاماتها ونفخر ونحمد الله
كثيرا على تشربنا تماما
شعبنا التي يعبر عنها بالمثل السمعه ولا
طوله العمر واذا عدم صدور الامر القضائي
المستحق قانونا لاسباب غير قانونيه نفصي
عنها لاحقا وفي ظل تسارع وتتابع الاحداث
وازدياد حده الاشتباكات وتعاظم النذر
والمخاطر من حولنا وفي ظل انشغال السلطات
الاخرى بمهامها في اداره المعركه الوطنيه
الان القائمه فقد اتخذنا قرارنا الخاص بنا
بان نتحمل مسؤوليتنا في حمايه انفسنا
بانفسنا وجاهزون للوصول امام السلطه
القضائيه متى ما تمكنت من القيام بمهامها
هي واجهزتها المسانده لها ثقه منا في
سلامه موقفنا القانوني ولنتقاسم مع شعبنا
ادوارهم بطوليه في الصبر والثبات والدفاع
عن كيان دولته من الاختطاف التحيه
والتقدير والنصر لشعبنا ولقواتهم المسلحه
وهم يقاتلون في معركه الكرامه الوطنيه
وندعو منسوبي دعم السريع المنحن للانخراط
مع اخوتهم في القوات المسلحه وترك
الالتزام تجاه قيادتهما الحاليه التي ثبت
انها تقودهم لمشروع شخصي واسري فقط تقبل
الله الشهداء وشف الجرحى ورد المفقودين
وواسل متضررين والمتاثرين والمصر الا صبر
ساعه ينصره الله فلا غالب لكم والله قالب
على امره احمد محمد هارون عن المعتقلين من
قيادات الانقاذ بسيم كوبر بتاريخ 25 ابريل
اذا من هو احمد هارون القيادي في نظام
الرئيس السوداني السابق عمر البشير والذي
خرج من سجن كوبر ابدى استعداده واخرون
للمثور امام القضاء
احمد هارون
من مواليد عام
1965 بمدينه الاوبيض
ينتمي لقبيله عربيه من شمال كردوفان
درس القانون بجامعه القاهره وتخرج عام
عاد الى السودان ليعمل في السلك القضائي
قاضيا
من العناصر البارزه في الحركه الاسلاميه
السودانيه
تم تعيينه وزيرا للشؤون الاجتماعيه في
ولايه جنوب كردفان
عين وزير الدوله في الداخليه عام 2003 بعد
ارتفاع وتيره التمرد في اقليم الدارفور
اختلف مع قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلو ما جعل الرئيس البشير يتدخل
للصلح بينهما
دخلنا في المشاكل وجاب لنا سمعه البطاله
احمد هارون يا اخي احنا ما ملائكه 6000
تراس هارون لجنه امن دارفور التي تتهمها
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بتجنيد وتسليح
الجنجويد وارتكاب انتهاكات واسعه
عين واليا لجنوب كردفان ومن ثم واليان
لشمال كردفان
من لندن ينضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي خالد
الراعيسر اهلا بك معنا السيد خالد اذا
لنتحدث قليلا حيث انتهى التقرير يعني خروج
سجناء من السجن في وضع كارثه مثل الوضع
الذي يمر به السودان كيف يؤثر اطلاق سراح
هؤلاء السجناء على الوضع في السودان
التحيه لمشاهديكم الكرام في تقديري ان
خروج السجناء الذي بدا منذ الخطوه الاولى
التي اقدمت عليها قوات الدعم السريع في
سيدنا الهدى بمدرمان واطلاق ثمانيه الاف
سنين ومن ثم انتقلت الى سجن النساء في
درمان حتى وصلت المرحله الاخيره وهي اطلاق
سجناء كوبر بكل بكل تاكيد ان الذين سجنوا
في تلك السجون وفي جرائم تتصل بجرائم
الجنائيه هؤلاء ربما يعني اطلاق صراحه في
هذا التوقيت سيشكل هاجس اضافي هاجس امني
اضافي باعتبار ان معظم الذين اطرحهم في
سيدنا الهدى على وجه التحديد هم من عتات
المجرمين الذين صدرت حولهم قرارات ومحاكم
السودانيه فيما يلي جرائم مختلفه
كذلك الحال مع السجن النساء ويمتد الامر
الى كوبرا اما على الصعيد السياسي انا في
تقدير الشخصي يعني الاوضاع الامنيه
الراهنه
يعني فشل بعض القائمين على امر السيون في
التصدي لقوات الدعم السريع في اختراقات
المتكرره وتعلمين ان السلطه التي تشرف على
هذه هي سلطه وزاره الداخليه ممثله في شرطه
السجون هذه لا تمتلك الاله العسكريه
الحربيه الضخمه حتى تتصدى لقوات الدعم
السريع في تعديات في الحاله التي تمثل
رموز النظام التي تقدير ان البيان الذي
صدر عن الجيش اليوم او صباح اليوم كان
واضحا ان الرئيس البشير وبعض القيادات
التي كانت في سجن كوبر هي
في احد المستشفيات العسكريه تحت اشراف
وحراسه المؤسسه العسكريه تحت اشراف
المؤسسه العسكريه السيد خالد استاذنك
بالبقاء معي لانتقل عاجلا الى ام درمان
ومراسلنا من هناك سالم الهاشمي لينقل لنا
الاشتباكات الحاصله هناك في المطار مطار
الخرطوم واتهامات الجيش للدعم السريع
باستخدام القناصه تفضل سالم
نعم اهلا بكم بكل ساده المشاهدين نحن هنا
في مدينه سبتمبر والتي شهدت اليوم
اشتباكاته متفرقات في مناطق متفرقه كذلك
من مدينه ام درمان وهذا ايضا جديد على
مدينه بالقرب من جسر
الفتيحاب الذي يربط
والخرطوم وهو واحد من الجسور التي كانت
مفتوحه تماما لحركه الماره ولتسهيل حركتهم
كذلك لكن اليوم
هذه المنطقه ولمبات تتحدث على ان قوات
الدعم السريع قد جاءت بتعزيزات عربات دخلت
الى مدينه ام درمان من الجهه الغربيه من
مدينه
هنا نحن الان في منطقه جوهره فيها
المواطنين بحثا عن الوقود في محطتين
للوقود واحده تعمل وبالتالي تعمل عليها
هذا الازدحام الذي يظهر الان في الشاشه
واضح جدا من هذه المنطقه للمواطنين وهذه
العربات التي مصطفى تبحث عن الوقود وواحده
لم تعمل بعده مع ذلك توجد سقوط مستمعه
لاجل البحث على الوقود هذه واحده من
المعضلات التي يعاني منها المواطن الان
لتوفير الوقود من اجل الحركه ومن اجل ايضا
ان تتحرك مساله الامدادات الغذائيه بهذا
الوقود وهي مشكله
ظلت موجوده منذ ان بدات هذه الاستضافات في
الاندلاع وتواصلت بعد بل ان هذا الالتحام
جعل ايضا اسعار الوقود غير
الناس تتحدث باسعار عاليه جدا في الحديث
عن اسعار الوقود وتتعامل ايضا بالسوق
السوداء بعض
الذين يعني يعملون في هذه السوق السوداء
وهذه ايضا ادت الى ارتفاع تذاكر السفليه
التي يغادر بها
مغادره العاصمه سواء الى الولايات او الى
مناطق متفرقه ايضا اثرت كذلك على اسعار
بعض السلع من الامور المؤسفه
لان هذه هي موجوده وتشهد قدره حقيقيه يضاف
الى هذه السلعه سلع اخرى ايضا
تشهد ندره
[تصفيق]
التي باتت
طبيعيه لكنها ما زالت تحتاج الى المزيد من
اجل ان ترجع الحياه بشكل طبيعي بتوفير كل
المواد التي يحتاجها
طيب
يعني
قليلا ولكن هل لك ان تستذكر معنا اتهامات
الجيش للدعم السريع باستخدام القناصه في
محيط المطار واستهداف من يستهدفون تحديدا
عندما يطلقون النار
نعم بالنسبه لاستهداف قوات الدعم السريع
هي
طيب
سالم يبدو اننا فقدناه
تفضل سالم انقطع الاتصال قليلا ولكن لست
معك الان هل تسمعني
[تصفيق]
طيب دعني اسالك سالم عن الوضع الانساني في
ام درمان حاليا يعني كيف يعيشون اثراء
ارتفاع الاسعار عدم وجود الوقود هل انت
معي سالم
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع مراسلنا
في ام درمان ونعود الى لندن والصحفي خالد
الاعسر ارحب بك مجددا خالد يعني كنا نتحدث
عن اطلاق سراح السجناء وتاثير ذلك على
مجريات المعارك على الارض ولكن لنتحدث
قليلا عن عمليات الاجلاء المستمره
والمتواصله والسريعه يعني الولايات
المتحده كانت تحدثت انها ترسل سفينه بحريه
ثالثه سريعه سرعتها عاليه نسبيا لماذا هذه
العجله في اجلاء المواطنين الاجانب من
السودان
خالد هل تسمعني
طيب
سيد خالد هل انت معي
نعم نعم اسمعي طيب تفضل كنت اسالك عن
العجاله في اجلاء المواطنين الاجانب من
السودان ما دلالات ذلك
قلت بالنظر الى المساحه الجغرافيه وبعد
الولايات المتحده من القاره الافريقيه
والبحر الاحمر هي بالتاكيد تحت الى وسيله
اسرع حتى تجري رعايا في السودان الذين هم
الاكثر عددا هناك اكثر من 15 الف مواطن
امريكي ربما او يعني في السودان وبالتالي
انا لا افسر الامر بخلاف ان السرعه مطلوبه
في باعتبار المساحه التي تفصل بالولايات
المتحده مع السودان تحتاج الى قدر من
السرعه هي ليست في اوروبا ولا ليست في عرض
البحر الاحمر كما هو الحال مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه التي لا تعد كونه الاف
الامطار
طيب خالد يعني هنا عاجل يريدنا على الشاشه
ويقول الدعم السريع بان قيادات الجيش لا
تلتزم بالهدنه وعلى المجتمع الدولي تحمل
مسؤولياته وقبل ذلك اتهم الدعم السريع
الجيش
بالهجوم على قواتهم في محيط القصر
الجمهوري وارض المعسكرات وسوبا كذلك في
وقت واحد اذا عادت الاشتباكات ووتيره
الاشتباكات للتصاعد هل هذا يعني ان الهدنه
قد انتهت هل هذا يعني بان سنرى مزيد من
التوترات والتصعيد بعد خروج الجاليه
الاجنبيه من السودان
انا في تقدير ان الدعم السريع لم يفيد
باقل شروط الالتزام بالقيم التي تتصل
بالحروب وحرب المدن والقوانين والقواعد
الدوليه المنظمه حتى لهذه الحروب التي هي
مخالفات في الاساس ولكن هناك يعني جزء
القانون الدولي الانساني هناك اشياء لا
يجب التعدي عليها من ضمنها حرمات البيوت
من ضمن حرمات المستشفيات من ضمنها ايضا
عدم اخراج الناس من المستشفيات من ضمن
ايضا عدم اتخاذ السكان دروع البشريه من
ضمن عدم اطلاق السجناء
اقامه الدعم السريع هي التي نشرت الفوضى
في الخرطوم هي التي ادت الى يعني
رهن الانسان السوداني الان في عدد من
الاحياء هي التي اخرجت الاسر من بيوت
لتسكن في البيوت هذه اشياء لا تتصل
بالقانون الدولي ولا بالعرف ولا بالاخلاق
والقيم السودانيه المعروفه الشعب السوداني
تربى على اصول هذه الاصول الان تبدو غايه
التصعيد في الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع هل تتوقع ان تزداد بعد خروج
الجاليه الاجنبيه وممثلي الدول من السودان
الجيش السوداني هو الحامي الوحيد وفق
القانون والدستور في اي حكومه صبغت في اي
برلمان
اوكلت مهمه حمايه الامن القومي السوداني
للجيش الوطني السوداني لا توجد دعم سريع
ولا توجد اي جسم موازي هذه قضايا فيها
يعني اما قصه التصاعد تصاعد الاعمال
الامنيه استطيع ان اؤكد لك وانقل عبركم
للشعب السوداني ان الجيش يعمل على احداث
اختراقات امنيه كبيره وجلب عدد ضخم من
القوات من خارج الولايات لاول مره تدخل
الخرطوم وان شاء الله لو موسى تصير الى ما
هو افضل لانه ليس في هذه الاثناء مناصير
الفتنه ساعاتي للهن نحن لسنا من دعاه حروب
ولكن لا يمكن ان نقبل ان يتعرض شعبنا
للتنكيل والترهيب والتخويف وبالتالي ندعو
الى هدنه ومن المصرين كنا ندعو للهدنه قبل
ان تنطلق الطلقه الاولى حتى نؤمن على هذه
المبادئ اولا وتواصلنا مع غيادات الدعم
السريع قبل ان تقدم على هذه الخطوه الانت
عاريه ممثلين في ض
يفك اخي يوسف عزت واخرين حول حمايته تحدثت
معهم قبل انزلاق الحديث
دار بيننا اننا كنا ندعوهم ان لا يقدموا
على خطوه من تصعيد وكنا بصدد الصلح بينه
وبين المؤسس العسكريه في سياق رؤيه وطنيه
بين نخبه وطنيه ترى ان هذه الحرب ستكون
وبال على الشعب السوداني وعلى الدعم
السريع وعلى قدرات الدعم السريع وعلى من
يديرون الدعم السريع على الشعب السوداني
وهذا ما حدث ضيفه يوسف عزت هذا نتحدثت
اليه شخصيا وتحدثت الى المقربين الى شخصيا
واجدادنا مجتهدنا ولذلك نحن لا نريد ان
تتصاعد الحرب
ماذا كان موقفهم من الهدنه
تكون هناك حرب حتى نتحدث عن الهدنه كنا
نتحدث عن ضروره الصلح بين الدعم السريع
وغياده
طبعا قبل الاشتباك وبالتالي نحن الان بعد
الاشتباك ندعوم من جديد يجب ان يوضع
السلاح جانبا وان نعود الى الافكار
القديمه في الحوار والتواصل نحن ابناء وطن
واحد اي نقطه دم منهم او من الجيش
السوداني فهمنا ونعزل لها اي حزن ابناء
الدعم السريع هم وابنائنا نحن ننظر اليهم
بنفس اساس العاطفي الموجه تجاه الجيش ذات
العاطفه توجهنا تجاههم لانهم ايضا الناس
ولكن يجب ان توقف هذه الحرب الان الان
وليس غدا وبالتالي انا وامي
وبالتالي عندها عندما تحدث عن الجيش
وضرورات تامين العاصمه انا اتحدث
عن قانون يخول للجيش النصوصا مكتوبه والتي
وافق عليها الشعب السوداني في برلمانات
المختلفه والمنتخبه ان يكون الجيش هو حامي
الوطن وحافظ الامن والاستقرار وليست دعم
السريع او اي سلطه اخر ولكن هذا لا يلغي
تعاطفنا واحترامنا وتقديرنا لقوات الدعم
السريعه ومن يشرفون عليها ومن يتحدثون
باسمها يجب ان يكون صوت العقل هو صوت يعني
الغاء فكره الحرب والدعوه الى هدنه جاده
ودائمه حتى الشعب السوداني ووجه
عبركم في الدول الخليج والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وكل الدول الاغريق ان تقدم يد
العون للشعب السوداني يمكن تقديم
المساعدات عبر الولايات هناك حكومات ولايه
في كل خريطه السودان يمكن ان تتواصل مع
هذه الدول لايصال مساعدات انسانيه مريحه
وعاجله من شان من بين الغذاء والدواء وهذا
امر ممكن مع دول الجوار الحول التي هي حول
السودان شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن الكاتب
الصحفي خالد العيسر
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات